what up guys code vlogs
day 8 episode 8 whatever it may be
ancient archer version 6
and we're having some render issues as
of right now
everything's actually going pretty good
overall
i just realized there were some critical
errors in how i was using
the graphic api of opengl so i am
analyzing
what uh
options i should be taking next here
and i have been using render doc and had
discovered
some pretty serious errors
and that's mainly
what is holding this back at the moment
but that's that's fine i'm going to
rewrite the renderer it's going to be a
lot better
but as of right now
you see it
it kind of works this is on the staging
branch so
uh
yeah it all works fine and this looks
good
but as i change things the issues have
prepped up so i'll capture a frame here
close this and we're going to look at it
in render dock real quick quick but
right off we see down here at the bottom
left
we have
366 issues basically because every
object i'm drawing with opengl has some
sort of index issue
now this uh improper use
was apparently hidden and you couldn't
really tell
in previous versions but now that i've
done something it has uh now caused some
issues
so
i've got to re-analyze that i've got
some good sources
but in the meantime
i'm kind of benching this for a little
bit and uh considering my options doing
some studying all that good stuff
i've been looking at unreal engine and
playing around with unreal engine so i
have a lot of
ideas for games and stuff and i have one
main one
um
that i kind of want to work on first and
i have a secondary one
that i also want to work on
this isn't an example of it right now
but uh
i've just been playing around in unreal
and getting used to it and seeing what
my options are and those sort of things
and getting used to how all the world
settings work and how project settings
work and just getting used to the
lighting it's so nice to have all the
rendering done for you because i spend
so much time
faffing about messing with rendering
and sometimes i just don't want to do it
anymore i just want to actually
write the story i'm trying to write and
start working on that so uh unreal
allows me to do that i haven't really
got to the story writing part but the
full game i'm still learning more but
it's been a really fun experience
and a lot a lot of little tests going on
and stuff
at the moment
so this is just an example game of
something well it's not even anything
i'm just these are just random levels i
made with obviously the default first
person
uh character shooting there
but i'm learning to replace all the
stuff and make my own and
learning how the game modes work is
pretty important
and of course i actually want to get in
and do some coding here with unreal
but
that's not too big of an issue
so here's another little thing i was
practicing
you know just some
getting all
animations figured out stuff like that
and
npcs and things like that this is just a
guy i put in here kind of walks around
this is just a big blank slate for
testing things
but ideally of course i want to have a
main character with
uh no i'm not going to talk about i'm
not going to get into the details of
what i'm
theorizing
but i just wanted to show you that hey
i'm in here kind of having fun oh this
is probably the coolest looking level
because i spent the most time on it i
don't know if it really has a purpose i
just kind of was like i'll just throw
some stuff together and have some fun
with it
and that's all this is really
now i guess i will give you the initial
theory
of what this game would be if it were
how i actually wanted i turned the
shooting sound off because they're super
super loud and annoying
but this is just another playground area
to test things out
ideally
wow is this building way too big
i don't know i guess it's about right
size
ideally this game would be
i don't know if i want to say
if this video gets uh 20 likes i'll make
a video about
extended stay the game and what i am
thinking about it because i don't know
if you guys actually want to hear me
getting into that when you're just
watching code vlogs you know
but yeah unreal it's uh
it's my kind of downtime side thing to
do right now when i'm not working on the
engine
and i'm really really learning to
enjoy it these world settings still
confuse me i'm still trying to figure it
out
because i want
i often want to have several game modes
so i'm like how do you have several game
modes and i think i kind of figured it
out
but i'm still not entirely sure because
i was going to make like a survival
system and just see what i could do with
that
nothing too serious just
kind of testing things out
and i was like okay so this overrides a
game mode i don't know
there's a lot to learn if you know any
super great unreal source i don't know
i've looked everywhere i don't already
but yeah tick interval that's kind of
cool to be able to control in a game
mode and then
just uh all this stuff i need to figure
out precisely what they do it does tell
you if you hover over them so that helps
but it's not often entirely clear enough
but it does look like if i go to the
full blueprint editor
i can do well this is the programming
stuff you have an event graph with a
begin play and a tick
and you can add
more event graphs
like comment
graph two
and i think you just add functions to
this
uh yeah i've got it open here
uh event
so you can add another tick yeah i can
add tick here too
there we go so i think you could do
multiple things with your game mode like
this with just multiple graphs of things
going on
because if you're having time and
considering how
i don't know it depends on the game of
course but if it's a survival game
which this could be i don't know still
playing around with that
you obviously want to
keep track of how fast your food is
going down so you can send updates like
hey it's been a tick how stressed has
your character been you know and apply
the appropriate things
so
i don't know if that's going to work
right okay we'll just i think i just
accidentally launched ancient archer
again
but obviously unreal is miles ahead of
my little
my little ghetto engine but i love my
little ghetto engine it's
it'll probably be
really good at some point but i'm not
going to rush it
it's more about this is more of a
learning experience
more than anything at this point
but another great thing about opengr
unreal and i started to say this and got
sidetracked is the source code is fully
available
so you can go check out their stuff and
i've been looking through this uh
there's way too much to like unpack
but it's kind of cool to be like okay
what's your runtime audio mixer from
files they have a lot of stuff a lot of
work has been put into this
engine
there's the a lot of definitions and
stuff for that
but it's pretty cool to
just go in here well cool to me i don't
know how cool it is to the average
person
if i'm feeling bored or if i'm looking
at something and wondering how they do
it it's just really nice to be able to
jump in here and
poke around i don't know if i'm actually
learning much
but because well it's so huge
there's just so much code that i don't
even know what to look for if i want to
look for a really specific thing you
know it's that kind of thing and even if
i do know what to look for how do i know
what they've named it how do i know
where they've put it because there seems
to be
just a lot of stuff
but you would think most of it's in
source
but there is there's like developer
stuff which i guess are developer tools
there's uh the whole editor front end
which i guess just hooks up to other
stuff
with the interface of the editor i'm
assuming
programs these are probably just like
third-party stuff
benchmark tool image validator yeah
slate viewer so just like some little
programs that are pre-compiled i'm
guessing
and i have to look at those more
and then run time i assume this is what
runs with your actual game
or whatever you launch
and there's a lot of stuff here
there's engine
there's like render core i think
and uh i was trying to unpack some of
this but i didn't get very far it will
definitely take some time
you know maybe that will be a good
stream we'll do like a 12 hour
unreal source code analysis marathon or
something
would you watch that
well that's uh
that's basically what i've been doing
these past few days and hope you enjoyed
this episode of code vlogs
it's uh
i don't know if this is the direction
that anyone expected
but i feel like it's what works for me
right now
and
yeah i guess that's it see you guys next
time
[Music]
you